hey everybody Jimmy here with bright
insight what you're looking at our
photos that I took myself and at the end
of this presentation I'm going to show
you three different videos as well then
I took while deployed to Iraq in August
of 2010 while in Mosul and Mosul is
located in the Nineveh province which is
historically famous and that there's a
story from the Bible of Jonah who was
swallowed up by the whale and three days
later he got out and apparently he
immediately went to the gates of NAR
Gaul which is the exact location where
you see me standing here and yeah that's
me in the photographs trying to look
cool
so these gates have been largely
restored but many aspects like the wall
for example is completely original
except for the top pieces like look at
this photograph here of the guard tower
where you see that there's been mortar
that's been added to restore the blocks
but the rest of the blocks are
completely just stacked upon each other
and the wall exceeds more than 30 feet
high and I'll show you some of the
figures here in a second
now these wing bowls as they're referred
to as they're also known as the lamassu
they're very mysterious the only thing
archaeologists can come up with is that
the must because they're not sure that
they must originate from the Assyrian
culture approximately 3,000 BC so in
other words 5,500 years ago or 4,500 or
choosing one thousand years before the
pyramids allegedly were built because
the textbooks tell us that they were
built 4,500 years ago which I disagree
with but that aside these are a thousand
years older than the pyramids are
supposed to be they're absolutely
massive there's dozens of them that
exist there's some in museums in Baghdad
and they also have been found in Iran
which is pretty incredible so whoever
made these were part of a civilization
that was very vast which historically we
know that Sumerians come from
Mesopotamia and they covered a vast area
so it's pretty incredible now the area
itself basically there's nine gates from
what I understand and it's surrounded by
this wall which is absolutely huge I
mean compared to the size of that van
right there
now it's also worth mentioning that the
iraqis do not take good care of this
location at all it's surrounded by a
bunch of burnt-out blown up and shot up
cars and vehicles from the war it's
pretty it's pretty screwed up
and right across the street from it is
an Iraqi police station which is what we
were doing there and I was one I was
very privileged to be able to go up and
check out these
these statues myself and again at the
end of the video I'll show you some some
actual video of it in me shooting it
which is pretty hilarious but I remember
going there and walking up as you can
see this walkway which is original from
what I understand or at least it appears
to be and I couldn't help but imagine
who how many armies and people had
walked up this before and just been
completely just it was really
interesting being there personally and
being able to witness it because I knew
I was in a very special old place that
was full of mystery and God knows how
much well history within itself now as
you can see in this photo of this plaque
and it's trying to depict which appears
to be slaves and I say that because the
person on the middle on the left
appears to be whipping them as they
carry up what appears to be I don't know
one of these statues or perhaps a person
a dead person the coffin I don't know
now I also need to mention that these
statues themselves as you can see in
this photo here was buried when they
found it which is really interesting
because how is it buried and when this
site in itself is also famous because
you may have seen down the news a couple
years ago when Isis was seen breaking
them up with the jackhammers and
sledgehammers and just pretty pathetic I
don't even think that they destroyed
them entirely they took them I remember
seeing video of it and they were having
difficulty even with the sledgehammers
and with the jackhammer because again
this is quartz guys this is really hard
stuff and if you go watch some video of
them actually trying to beat it I mean
yeah they break it up but it didn't look
too easy and that's what freaking power
tools so it really makes you wonder now
look at these other photographs of the
wall and again it surrounds an area that
is apparently twelve kilometers I think
is the perimeter and I'm going to show a
picture up here that has the description
that's poorly translated but you can
read it for yourself press pause now if
you want to read it but again I want to
point out just the amazing precision
it's not until you touch these things
yourself I remember knocking on these
these statues with my with my hand with
my knuckles even always wearing a glove
it still hurt I was astonished by just
how solid and hard it feels and when you
look at just the fine details they have
within the beard the feathers and the
underbelly of this being that this
person this guy's face with a big beard
and this
ox or horse body with massive wings it's
reaiiy don't what made them come up with
this and why did they build dozens of
them in the first place is it just
symbolism I mean really what is this is
this part of something else that we just
can't even imagine I have no idea but
the precision in itself I can't imagine
the fact that this is made out of
quartzite which is a seven out of ten on
the most skill of hardness I mean it's
harder than rose granite okay so it
makes you wonder how they're able to do
something so detailed even if they had
steel which we know they didn't it's a
Bronze Age culture allegedly where these
came from
so they shouldn't have had anything
other than copper to work with and
modern-day stonemasons utilize diamond
bit drills and they acknowledge that
because of the hardness you can't even
shape these without having steel but
even if I had to steel pick even if they
had that that's a which apparently they
don't but if they did and we're just not
aware of it I couldn't even imagine how
to doing something so precise because
quartzite is full of crystals so it
would be so rugged and rigid I should
say and breaking up I don't know guys
yeah to me this is absolute evidence of
lost ancient high technology and there's
far more to the story of these winged
Bulls than what the frickin Wikipedia
page says so keep that in mind now real
quick I want to show you these
photographs so when I was in Mosul I was
on fob Marez which is part of a
Diamondback which was the airbase there
it doesn't exist anymore obviously since
we left
but st. Elijah's monastery which is
Iraq's oldest monastery apparently which
originates from the 6th century so in
the year 500 something this was made and
it has a rich history that well
apparently has been massacred multiple
times by invaders and everyone else but
it's incredibly old and it makes you
wonder the story behind it for something
that is again we're talking 1500 years
ago this was built but Isis also blew it
up or bulldozed it you can see it in
these photos here and that was on the
news not long ago but a few years ago so
it's pretty disturbing anyways guys let
me know your thoughts take a look at
these videos now they're going to go
ahead and play for you back-to-back two
of them are at the site of Nergal and
the third one is just driving past the
Saint Elijah - monastery on the way to
the test fire pit before going on
mission in Iraq anyways guys I'm Jamie
this is bright insight like and
subscribe leave a comment watch the
videos coming up right now
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah for tourists in Iraq
[Applause]
yeah a third
other
people
[Applause]